yeah like the girls are all [ __ ]
talking like dick dick dick dick [ __ ]
dick and then Julie drops a bomb and the
chat just goes quiet for a second and we
just all freaked out the girls are a
bunch of horn dogs yeah do that chat is
so awesome I love that that's so funny
cuz like i JK guys don't talk like that
yeah a lot of people think like guys
talk like that no dude it's the girls
yeah and I think like us guys do like we
don't really talk about that [ __ ] like
we just kind of like whatever and I
don't know why but it would be very
weird for me to hear about sexual
conquests that they've had with a girl
that I'm thinking that I'm know that I'm
supposed to now if it was some random
girl that's a different thing because I
don't have any like emotional connection
to her let's say you know like that's
why I never watched ask the feels I
couldn't I couldn't watch it yeah I
clicked on it once and then it was
something about like I [ __ ] Geo like
eating coming over scarred me I was like
klicks out we don't click out at this
point we only don't click out because
today we got a group text from Tim and
all the girls he's like Oh should I
forgot to send you this photo so it's a
photo of the like the four of us like
meet if Gio Shannon he's are afraid to
send you this from the wedding and then
so everyone I go thanks and Shannon goes
I heard about this group text or this
group chat by the way I want in is there
an application process because we
recently just let bows in oh yeah yeah
bows must be [ __ ] funny but this is
great I love to shout to Bozeman she's
one of my favorite people on earth like
she makes me happy
yeah I feel like if anyone would make
bows like even mildly inconvenienced I
would want to kill them Smosh but and
this sounds like I want in and then now
we have to like we have to consult the
you know like the art table yeah because
all the committee let him in our robes
is shot and allowed to come in the
candles mayhaps we have a giant booger
shannon if you wish to be a part of us
slice your hand and shake ours with the
cut of our cut and may our blood unite
it used to be called a host base uh-huh
that was the name of the group then we
changed it recently to the restroom
because drunk girls at a club in the
bathroom are the most supportive [ __ ]
you'll ever meet in your life
did I I said that's like the stand-up
said about the shits like it's kind of
like I've noticed how girls hype each
other up like guys don't do that [ __ ]
for each other like girls are the
[ __ ] funniest people on earth like I
see girls like when I see Mariel get
ready and her best friends with her -
they're like oh my god look at those
earrings you look good you're always
gonna get this earring for you but I
thought it would be better for [ __ ]
Jess so I look better on her but let me
tell you some of the hoops that you have
on are [ __ ] crazy oh my god what are
the [ __ ] did you get those palms dude I
was I wasn't sure about it right and so
okay so the other day right so I was
trying you guys go on this diatribe
and then oh my god your [ __ ] titties
look great today really you think so I
wasn't feeling that good you're [ __ ]
stupid I would [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you
right now if I was a guy I remember when
I wasn't I was like I was in Taiwan for
a month for a good gig and then I was
dating and one said his name our mutual
yeah yeah yeah so I used to date one of
David's friends but um I remember I
haven't seen him for like a month he
said he'll send me a booty pic I'm like
I got you I told my girlfriend I was
like yo my man means an ass photo she's
like I got you
and she's like hittin in all angles like
that's like girls are supportive when we
want to be it's awesome that's so
[ __ ] funny dude
I'm in like a makeup group rate and one
of the girls like hey I won't let you
guys know if you want to cover up any
marks that your parents don't want to
see you use this I had dinner with my
mom she didn't see a thing and then I
comments I was like damn now we can all
ho in peace this is great guys are such
disgusting creatures did you guys are so
[ __ ] I love it so much because like
like I love I love women who are so just
like they have a firm grasp on their
sexuality
like Shannon like is a goddess to me
vibrators ologist yeah dude like she is
a goddess to me and I love people like
that you know
you know I have so many questions about
women I'm right Shannon what was the
clitoris where's the clitoris do you
know when I was in fifth grade they had
sex ed class and they were teaching her
they separated the girls and they were
teaching girls how to put tampons and
use pads and stuff like that and I was
the only one that raised my hand and
said excuse me
what's a vagina and should the ladies
look at me she goes um the bigger hole
and I'm sitting there blowing like
there's more than what I could watch who
holds this do it and then like everyone
started laughing around me I was like
that's have you [ __ ] know what the
[ __ ] vagina is like you don't [ __ ]
know but I was that kid okay the [ __ ]
it's it's so well Bart didn't even
[ __ ] know there was two holes Bart
didn't know there was a pee hole in a
regular Regina did that's just [ __ ]
hilarious dude crazy so the funny thing
is like for me like when people ask me
like yo how did you so I'm very open
when it comes to like sexual things like
number one and I learned this only from
one [ __ ] girl so when I was younger
guys are so funny because guys always
talk about their sexual cut everybody's
the hero in their own story specifically
guys when it comes to their sexual
conquests right I've always talked about
this before is and because of that type
of rhetoric you like young men I believe
they feel pressure to be like the best
at sex like they have to [ __ ] smash
the [ __ ] out the [ __ ] park on their
first try right because the guys never
talk about how bad they were the first
[ __ ] time and they always think that
they're amazing and a lot of the times I
think when girls are really young they
feel like it's their responsibility to
kind of boost up this guy self-esteem
when they [ __ ] right so there's this
Filipino girl that I was with she was
very hyper sexual and our relationship
actually didn't work out because of how
hyper sexual she was and in in her sense
she actually related affection with
sexuality so if we weren't [ __ ] every
day she thought that something was wrong
with us because the guys that she was
with the only the way they would connect
with her is that they would [ __ ] her for
me it was never like that number one at
that time I was trying to be a stand-up
comic do music I was working two [ __ ]
jobs and I was doing all this other [ __ ]
so Manhasset
yeah you know and so for her but they
would they would they would [ __ ]
consistently and I remember when we
broke up or when we had blister we'll
talk about that after but when we had
sex yeah let me tell you this time I was
like I asked I was like how was it she
was like what you with what you mean man
well what what what man mean what was
many what you mean man as in me as in
like you you was [ __ ] me or you say
like me eh like man like whatever she's
like it was okay yeah but she was very
open and honest with me she's like no I
just like you just kind of like you just
kind of [ __ ] just the [ __ ] outside I
thought if you just think it and it
feels good
well I didn't know because nobody was
honest with me about that and that at
that point she was like my third or
fourth sexual partner and prior to that
nobody said anything right and I think
is because they were they were catering
to my ego and mind you that's because I
think a lot of guys need their ego
stroked yeah right so maybe I've just
been always a little weird so I just
well I'll say okay well [ __ ] tell me
how to do this right then cuz I don't
[ __ ] know I don't know so you tell me
so [ __ ] it all right yeah my [ __ ]
scroll out a Chinese started write
calligraphy what the hell you mean
okay clitoris this way okay figure eight
around the [ __ ] bachelor clearance okay
sure okay maybe the [ __ ] sometime
okay okay a little yeah okay
buh-buh-buh-buh
okay okay finger here finger here put
the mouth on the car was there wait till
you'll come don't come so early
it's true though because like as a woman
I've been in that situation where
they're like oh how is it I really want
to say [ __ ] sucked but like it's like
cuz then men are so they like the
society always house like men are so
sensitive about their death game they
really are though they are you know
that's not even like that's not there's
no [ __ ] debate about yeah but it's
like men have to be accepting of
critique to you know it's like if I tell
it like for instance I actually like
there's a one guy that I was dating
I spoke about him before words like this
is a smallest penis I've ever seen in my
life like if I were to hold it in my
hand it did not pop out on the top yeah
mm-hmm you know you know what sorry like
I like I told him I don't really have
sex like I'm not a first date [ __ ] like
I made him wait like three months okay
and then after three months it was like
three months of buildup and then
catastrophic failure oh yeah I mean if
it